تفعل رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مع
مشهد مؤثر لانثى شمبانزي وهي تحتضن صغيرها
بعد غيابه عنها لمده يومين نتيجه معاناته
في صعوبه في التنفس بعد ولادته في حديقه
الحيوانات بامركا
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو اثار جدلا واسعا في مصر يدعم
صاحبه انه عثر على فتاه محبوسه في شقه
مهجوره مع والدها وهي تصرخ طلبا للطعام
سكان المبنى وزاره الداخليه تحركت لكشف
تفاصيل الواقعه وتبين ان الشاب عند زيارته
لاحدى قريباته ابلغته بوجود فتاه في شقه
بالطابق الارضي وانها دائمه تصرخ وتطلب من
الاهالي الطعام توجه الرجل مع قريبته
للالتقاط الفيديو لكن تبين بحسب الوزاره
ان الاب وابنته مضطربان عقليا فهو يقوم
بالخروج لطلب الطعام من الاهالي ويغلق باب
الشقه خشيه على ابنته من الخروج
يا جدعان احنا لسه واخدين الشقه في
العماره ديت بقى لنا اسبوعين اتفاجئت ان
في واحده محبوسه في الدور الارضي
والله انا مش فاهم
[موسيقى]
مواقع
برفقه ابنته الصغيره لاول ظهور الرسمي لها
التي لم يتم الافصاح عن اسمها خلال تجربه
اطلاق نوع جديد من الصواريخ البالستينيه
البالستيه العابره للقاره حيث تعتبر حياته
الخاصه من الاسرار داخل الدوله ولا يعرف
عنها سوى القليل في حين لفتاه وكاله
كولومبينج الامريكيه الى ان ظهورها يمثل
تلميعها لخطط الخلافه داخل الاسره الحاكمه
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء